بنظرات مملوءه بالشكل والحيره والازعاج
رامقتنا هذه القطه بعد ما اقتحمنا عالمها
في هذه السياره المتهلكه التي اتخذتها
منزلا
مئه الالاف من السيارات والمركبات
المتهلكه تملا شوارع العاصمه بل والمدن
المصريه تكفى لا تشكل ملاذا للقطط
والحيوانات فقط ولكنها تشكل خطوره امنيه
وبيئه غير امنه فضلا عن ازدحام الشوارع
بها
تجار المخدرات
لازم نعرف مين عربيه مين دي مركونه بتاعه
مين ومكونه ليه وفين مشكلته هذه المركبات
المهمله ادت الى تدخل رئاسي لانهائي اشغال
الطرق بالسيارات والمركبات المهمله التي
تعيق سريعه تطوير في البنى التحتيه التي
بدات مصر وتخفيف ازدحام الشوارع فضلا عن
تصفيه مقابر السيارات التي تضم الاف
السيارات المصادره في قضايا مختلفه وتصنيف
ما يمكن اعاده الاستفاده منه او احالته
الى التكهين
في كل محافظه هتلاقي فيه مقابر السيارات
يعني كان في كذا مقبره في القاهره على
سبيل المثال كان وكبار جدا الاستفاده اللي
هترجع لنا من موضوع ان احنا هنقضي على
العربيات المتهلكه اللي موجوده دي العربيه
دي ما كانتش ما كانش فيه منها اي استفاده
لما يتم اعاده تدوير هذه السيارات ممكن
احنا بعد كده او تقطيع القطع الغيار
بتاعتها احنا ممكن يتم عمل سكرابييرس تبع
الحكومه او حتى يتم بيعها في مزادات قراره
التخلص من المركبات المتهلكه لا قطر ترحبا
كبيره
المواتير ديت بتجمع كلها بيت عليها مزاد
متهلكه وبايظه ومركونه ومريم زباله
والكلام ده دي تتشال الاستفاده من
المركبات المتهلكه ستنعكس ايجابيا بتخفيف
الزحام الشوارع فضلا عن اعاده التدوير
والحصول على قطع غيار مستعمله باسعار
زهيده واسطه موجه الغلاء الحاليه راندا
ابو العزم العربيه القاهره